[Musique]
bienvenue si vous venez de nous
rejoindre sur tv fil 78
si vous avez suivi mercredi le débat de
la 11e circonscription vous avez
constaté qu'en raison de certains
débordements
elle nous avions été contraints de
rendre l'antenne les échanges entre
candidats n'ayant pu se poursuivre et
dans un respect du temps de parole de
chacun durant cette campagne je vous
propose d'écouter 4 des participants à
ce scrutin dont le premier tour se
déroule je vous le rappelle le dimanche
11 juin au total ce sont 13 candidats
qui se disputent le poste de député la
liste complète s'affiche sur votre écran
et pour connaître les résultats ici et
dans le reste des yvelines rendez vous
êtes dimanche ce dimanche à partir de
19h30 en direct
une page politique à présent avec un
candidat représentant durée npa dans la
11e circonscription bonsoir à vous et
nous allons passer directement à une
carte blanche vous avez à présent une
minute pour vous exprimer
est sur la thématique de votre choix
dans cette campagne qu'elle est la
problématique la plus importante pour
vous ce qu'on voudrait dire nous c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui il ya des fuites
qui sont sortis dans la presse si on
veut sur le sujet des ordonnances de
contrôle à la casse du code du travail
que vous organisez monsieur macron il
son gouvernement et nous ce qu'on
voudrait dire c'est qu'évidemment contre
cette voie travail numéro deux il va
falloir lutter parce que le gouvernement
qu'on a aujourd'hui des républicains qui
est un mix et républicains du ps dans
marche
si on se bat pas contre cette loi ça
nous prévoit vraiment des jours
difficiles
ce que par exemple cette casse du code
du travail c'est quelques exemples de ce
qui est prévu le plafonnement des années
des indemnités de licenciement est
essentiellement aussi un point
primordial c'est la primauté des accords
d'entreprise qui permettra en fait tout
et n'importe quoi un peu si le patron
trouve quelques syndicats signataires
minorité puisque aujourd'hui c'est 30%
des dessins de représentativité il
pourra y compris changer les modalités
de licenciement et changer la forme et 2
la raison d'un licenciement c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a trois classes de
licenciement le cause réelle et sérieuse
faute grave faute lourde il pourra
inventer une nouvelle mesure pour dix
ans y ait des salariés compris quasiment
sans raison donc pour ça il ya déjà des
mobilisations qui se met en place il ya
le front social qui s'organisait qui a
manifesté déjà deux fois le 22 avril et
lui mais il y avait des milliers de
personnes égales alors le front social
c'est un groupement d'associations et de
syndicats qui se regroupent pour lutter
contre cette politique de casse sociale
et l'essentiel pour nous ce qu'on veut
dire c'est qu'il ya une mobilisation
importante prévue dès lendemain du
premier tour le 18 juin il y aura un
rassemblement devant l'assemblée
nationale
18 heures devant l'assemblée nationale
donc à paris ce jour là et il faudra
être très nombreux ce jour là pour
lutter contre monsieur de la crau et son
gouvernement à vincent fournier merci
candidat npa dans cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines
également candidat dans la 11e
yacine amarres pour l'upm bonsoir et aux
électeurs en une minute pourquoi voter
tout simplement pour vous qu'est-ce qui
vous résout qu'est ce qui vous a engagé
au sein de l'upm notamment alors je suis
à du père car c'est un parti qui est
sérieux et constant dans ses
propositions qui instruit des citoyens
en fournissant des analyses
claire et cohérente et qui me permet
d'apporter ma contribution dans la vie
politique je vais me présente pour
pouvoir pour promouvoir les idées de
l'upper afin de gagner en visibilité
médiatique
il faut savoir que nous plus nous
faisons de voix et plus nous pouvons
nous exprimer dans les médias et
présenter nos idées aux français mais
aussi pour gagner en moyens financiers
car chaque voix représente 1 euros 40 de
financement public par an donc chaque
voix compte du père présente cinq cent
soixante quatorze candidats dont 98% qui
sont issus de la société civile
de ce point de vue nous sommes le plus
gros parti politique de france
si je suis élu je m'engage à être
présents à l'assemblée nationale à la
transparence en reportant régulièrement
les dossiers traités à l'assemblée
nationale a dénoncé des pratiques
illégales ou immorales de la vie
politique et à faire des réunions
publiques pour permettre le dialogue
avec mes concitoyens de la
circonscription
j'invite tous nos téléspectateurs à
seraing dessus rupert point fr pour
consulter notre programme et nos
analyses et je les incite dimanche à
faire un vote de conviction et je
remercie tv fil 78 de m'avoir donné la
parole ce soit merci yacine amar
candidats de l'upm dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
un autre candidat à présent dans cette
11e circonscription des yvelines qui
couvre notamment à la commune de trappes
et il en est originaire mathieu ruffey
bonsoir pour le nouveau souffle c'est le
nom de votre mouvement pourquoi avoir
décidé de vous vous engagez dans cette
bataille des législatives sur cette
circonscription
merci d'ailleurs des matériaux donc
c'est à dire que on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui en tant que jeunes issus des
classes populaires de ne pas être
représenté
que ce soit à l'assemblée ou au
gouvernement quand on voit la moyenne
d'âge de l'assemblée nationale ça fait
peur et je trouve aussi qu'il n'ya pas
assez de remise en question de notre
propre système démocratique il n'y a pas
assez de participation citoyenne
je suis favorable à la reconnaissance du
vote blanc bien entendu il ya tout un
tas de mesures qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre aujourd'hui à l'aide des
nouvelles technologies d'information et
de communication de faire participer les
gens en termes de réactivité avec les
smartphones avec internet comme
véritable outil des soeurs démocratique
et je trouve aujourd'hui on titille
uniquement l'intérêt électoral de
lecteurs plus que sont sa mobilisation
politique
on confond mobilisation électorale est
maudit cette mobilisation politique et
je pense que c'est vraiment la jeunesse
qui en dehors de tout formatage qui est
capable de reprendre les choses en main
je pense que la chance vraiment de la
france aujourd'hui c'est
l'intellectualisation sa jeunesse
populaire et il faut davantage d'hommes
politiques qui réfléchissent aux causes
plus que de réagir aux conséquences je
pense aussi que il ya trop de
gestionnaires trop de technocrates et
peu de citoyens
le clivage gauche droite aujourd'hui n'a
plus de sens y compris d'un point de vue
économique je pense que l'état doit
reprendre les choses en main en tant que
véritables acteurs économiques pour
dégager de la pression fiscale et a
énormément de sujets sur lesquels les
citoyens et les jeunes ont énormément
d'idées ils ne sont pas suffisamment
écoutés ils ne sont pas suffisamment mis
en avant
c'est pourquoi mon avis la jeunesse
issue des classes populaires a son mot à
dire et doit se présenter pour aller à
l'assemblée nationale dida pour le
nouveau souffle dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
merci
christina gas représente lutte ouvrière
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
bonsoir expliquez-nous voir une minute
pourquoi à voter pour lutte ouvrière
quelles sont les valeurs que vous
défendez dans ce scrutin
notre camp c'est le camp des
travailleurs et les valeurs que l'on
défend
effectivement pour nous travailleurs sur
meurtre était jeune on est victimes tous
de la domination du capital a et 2 et
des divisions qu'il ' notre sort ne
dépend pas des urnes quel que soit le
résultat des urnes des législatives quel
que soit le parti qui aura la majorité
parlementaire il défendra les valeurs de
la bourgeoisie et les vrais donneurs
d'ordres au gouvernement il ce qui
dicteront leurs lois resteront les
principaux actionnaires des grandes
sociétés comme actuellement est pour
nous un manque ablement les lois qui
feront nous révolteront nous ferons
des grèves des manifestations et pour
que ce ne soit pas le front national qui
dit qu'ils essayent de nous diviser
entre travailleurs selon nos origines de
pays où voilà notre carte d'identité ou
notre religion
nous n'avons rien à gagner dans ce nous
sommes une seule classe ouvrière et nos
intérêts sont communs avec tous les
travailleurs et la planète voilà c'est
les valeurs que nous défendons et nous
pensons que voter pour nous pour les
travailleurs qui se reconnaissent dans
ce que l'on dit est une force parce que
il le faudra se réunir ce pour
construire effectivement une force
capable de résister au capitalisme et le
renverser merci christine elias
candidate donc dans cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines ils sont
treize va se présenter à ce scrutin
premier tour dimanche au 11 juin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]